alright we got a pretty decent crowd
here for for Monday night a lot of new
faces which I love to see so it should
be a pretty good one we're gonna do
something a little bit different today
normally we go over one opening
particularly one variation and we go
really deep into it but today I'm gonna
take a suggestion from one of our
YouTube people that mentioned me and
they wrote a comment and so for Dan
Williams who writes can you guys do a
video of the top 10 most common openings
using e4 with a little synopsis of each
as well as the best possible defense for
black to play verse each that'd be great
thanks so yeah I think Dan this is a
great idea
and you really know how to ingratiate
himself to me when he posted in another
tweet or sorry another comment I
advertised your videos on my Twitter
YouTube and Facebook so thanks Dan for
sharing my stuff around and thanks for
the excellent idea so tonight we're
going to do a top 10 video and it's
going to be the top 10 most common
responses to the movie for now this
could be interpreted a couple different
ways I could do a video it's mostly all
Sicilians and really Lopez's that's sort
of a thing but I'm going to take this
position here and we're going to look at
the top 10 moves that black can play
from this position who can tell me how
many legal moves Black has yeah 20 right
so the pawns each have two moves so
that's 16 and then there's two Knight
moves each makes 20 so we're going to go
over half of the possible moves that
black can play and I use the database of
four million games to prepare this and
just you know the the top 10 moves
account for 98 or 99 point eight percent
of all the total openings so there's
only about 5,000 games where they didn't
play something that you're going to see
tonight and I apologize in advance if
some of the openings I have to go kind
of quick normally we go deep into
opening we're going wide tonight we're
going to try to cover a whole lot in a
little bit of time here so alright
starting out with number 10 we have the
wins defense now this has been played
in this the databases here on this
computer 12,000 times which is 0.3
percent of all II for games so you're
not going to see this very often but you
don't want to be surprised when you do
see it and you know I've seen a lot of
my students they always ask you know how
I got to know so much when I play e4
well yeah you got to know something like
this sometimes your opponent might
surprise you and typically when I have
played this I play it against lower
rated players when I play people under
1200 I play this and sometimes you win
quickly so we'll go over it so the most
natural move is just to take the center
when they let you take it you take it
and Bishop b7 and this is blacks point I
will draw with our fancy new arrows you
know see the see the gradient ok we're
already attacking the pawn it's a very
interesting approach and so what should
defend it and there's different ways to
do so the big question is what's going
to happen with this Knight here is is it
going to go to c3 is it going to go to
d2 both of these are very common and
another question is what's to become of
this pawn is he going to support the
center is he going to go to c4 and so
there's different ideas in each and of
all the openings we're going to cover
tonight this one is sort of the dodgiest
it has the worst reputation and having
played it against decent people weight
has several ways to get a pleasant
advantage in this line which is why it's
not so popular now most often what
blacks plan is if white ever does adopt
a setup with Knight to c3 is he's going
to play e6 and the Bishop's going to go
up in the night and usually will end up
taking and doubling the pawns it's all
in an effort to take control over the e4
square so these lines are very playable
but the most common move is actually
Bishop to d3 not moving the knight just
yet not allowing a future pin so ok
Black has the main move which is e 6
it's worth looking briefly at the crazy
move f5 which shouldn't be very good but
lines get very very complicated here
White has sort of the amazing move looks
like you know
is going to go take that pawn that's
this point there's a pin here but the
most critical line is actually to accept
this so what's going on we take the pawn
we're going to win your rook and I've
had people ask you know why why do you
have that rule don't move your F pawn
well a lot of the times either people
they put upon where their knight can go
so then then I can't go there that's one
reason you don't want to move an F pawn
but in this case - you always want to be
on the lookout for the the Queen check
on this long diagonal and here that's
the best move so blacks move is totally
forced you only got one move and all
right now white can take it now there's
a famous Greco game he played it in 1620
against no-name and his opponent played
here thinking he's very cunning he's
sorry now you're going to move your
queen and I'm not going to get
checkmated but white has a very nice
tactic here who can see what a what
white played in this position mm-hmm g7
check that is a roof yeah okay so so
this we are
okay so yeah this seems right but you
actually have a better pond move you can
you can take this thing
so check flex move is forced and okay
checkmate
yeah and the other line when you just
push I still have control over g6 so
yeah you got to take the pawn okay and
that's why in this position after these
forced moves the way black can continue
is with Bishop to g7 and now after this
check the king will have to move and you
can take the knight with check perhaps
Knight to f3 is even a stronger move and
you get really crazy scenarios you know
white already has this pawn way down
here and an opening of course he's
losing the rook here in the corner and
all right that's an interesting line to
know about but we're going to look we're
gonna yeah we're gonna look at the main
line here which is the movie six so
again if you play Knight c3 we're going
to pin it and so we develop our other
night we're not telling you where this
guy's going just yet
and at some point Black has to attack
the center so now is a decent time in
the pleasure of playing this position is
even as white you can go ahead and
castle here if you want to play a
Sicilian type structure this is
perfectly playable for white and in
these lines white gets pretty good a
game but more common is c3 just
protecting the center now black will
develop and it's important also in this
opening for white to time his move e5 he
doesn't necessarily want to do it too
early and give the knight access to d5
so typically here he will protect his
pawn black will develop it so it's worth
knowing this little trick I guess Knight
to c6 is already a big inaccuracy
because after d5 black is in a lot of
trouble due to the pin on this file here
the fact W discovered checks so this
would be just losing and if you have to
move your knight and I get to play a
move like c4 then this guy is looking
pretty silly this guy is out of play and
White has a big space advantage in a
very nice position so it's already would
be quite bad for black black has to be
be quite accurate in these lines just to
survive the opening here okay so we
Castle now they can play it now that
there's a
locking on the e-file now if you play d5
we can just take it so a three black is
also threatening in this position to
take let's waste a move to take here on
d4 and play Knight to b4 and if he picks
up this bishop then he's doing very well
it's a strategical success he gets to
pick up the bishop pair which explains
the move a 3 and ok now white play our
black plays sort of an interesting move
he puts the knight on the side and
there's a tactical basis for this that's
coming up on the next move black really
wants to you know plop this knight in
here that harass the rook maybe he'll
get to take one of the bishops so you
got to defend the beast 3 square so
that's what happens Bensimon is looking
at his watch at some point our cameraman
is going to leave and then who knows
what's gonna happen tonight so I should
be what I should have three done already
is that true oh we're in a lot of
trouble tonight
and Ben's leave it where it's all going
to fall apart I can just tell
okay so what defended the B 3 square and
we'll go a little farther here's the the
tactical point the move c4 and okay wait
a minute what's going on we got two
pieces attacking c4 but uh what's this
three alright you can count a little bit
better than me okay but if you take here
the point is we're removing the defender
of the e pawn so here you'd be able to
grab this guy and black frees himself a
little bit so okay you want to keep your
Bishop so you move it and alright we
still haven't committed to a plan the
most flexible move here Queen c7 white
continues alright what's up Danny
Machuca
you know this position Danny is this
position you've been talking about
okay and there's also a question now
which way will black castle
alright this suppose he goes King's side
and it's time for white to come up with
a plan and an interesting little move
will stop after this move he's making
sure that if his bishop ever moves or
his knight has to move that this move
isn't coming with a gain attempt oh and
white is slightly better here he's going
to maneuver his knight around he's going
to go try to attack the black King he
might play h4 h5 try to provoke some
weaknesses and that's the right moment
he's going to play e5 and get this
Bishop going so so there we go
I think then Bensimon is out of here so
who knows what's going to happen but all
right that's a brief introduction to the
Owens defense now coming in at number
nine let's let's reverse a little bit
coming in at number nine we have the
nimzowitsch defense which is the move
Knight to c6 and I think out of all of
them this one is sort of the most
underrated black can get sort of a
decent position it's not as suspicious
as it might look you know why would you
put that night in front of your pawn
what does that move even accomplish and
the most testing move is to play d4 that
seems like the most natural but you
might be surprised to learn Knight f3 is
actually the most common move here and I
think people pick this more for
practical reasons than an attempt to
outright refute Blacks play now they're
they're probably ready for this if
they're an e4 player this will just
transpose into a King's pawn game d5 is
also possible you'll get sort of a
Scandinavian type position more to keep
just with the nimzowitsch defense if you
want to keep it outside the realm of any
other openings you don't want to
transpose to anything you can play the
move d6 but we're going to focus on the
critical move here d4 and there's two
moves that black likes to play in these
positions either d5 or a 5 if a 5 we can
now transpose to a Scotch which is why a
lot of black players might you know not
want to play this way they're trying to
get their opponent out of book so e5 is
not as common but even after this we can
kick the knight around
and it can retreat either way it can
actually go to b8 but let's go to e7 and
black intends just to bring his night
out we won't go too deep into this but
that's the most common move not the only
move and black will get his Bishop out
if there's a night here on c3 Iza he's
going to pin it and often he's going to
take it and this nights going to go here
and he's going to get his pieces out and
it'll be kind of a slow maneuvering game
so this is interesting but more keeping
in the theme of the opening is d5 okay
most common is to push and now black
gets his Bishop outside of the pawn
chain before he plays the movie six and
if you know of the French we marred
you'll notice this looks quite a lot
like that variation in the advanced
French which I've been known to play
from time to time the big downside in
blacks position here is this knight in
this structure he's going to want to
play the move c5
but now there's knight in the way on the
other hand unlike most French advances
you know you got this bishop out if you
put your pawn on e6 I'll move one
normally you don't get to put your
bishop out on f5 so we get quite an
interesting position okay Bishop d3
right now immediately drops upon Knight
takes d4 does work for black so most
often they protect it f6 is a
interesting move here but e six is
typical and alright we'll get a position
here where all right not the only move
very similar to the the Guim art and
we'll just we'll stop here for for
brevity's sake all right coming in at
number eight let's do this first coming
in at number eight we have Alekhine's
defense or alley Ekans defense okay this
has been played 92 thousand times and
which is about two point two nine
percent of the time so not the most
common but very provocative he's
encouraging white to advance the pawn in
attack his knight so what's going to
happen here so white will normally push
the only other move worthy of any
theoretical discussion is night two
see three but okay we'll push will play
the critical line and now there's you
know quite a lot of ways white can play
he can move all of his pawns the four
pawns attack he can develop very
modestly a lot of different lines and so
d4 is just the most logical you're just
taking control of the center with your
pawns also possible is c4 as in the
famous game nakamora Schwantz from 2011
you know that game yeah alright yeah
okay so that's that's interesting but
we're going to focus here on d4 and flex
point why did he do this why did he you
know force white to make all these pawn
moves maybe he wanted to he's going to
try to argue that this pawn has been
overextended so I have to remove like d6
attacking the center and white needs to
make a choice he can simply develop his
knight that's that's fine and we'll look
at that in a second or he can decide to
play the move c4 and after we retreat
either the exchange variation which is
interesting
okay black can take either way so okay
this is just possible 4/4 time let's
let's look at the four pawns attack here
and all right this is this is quite an
attempt to blow black off the board and
if you look in the databases there's
some short games in this position
because if black isn't careful he can
get crushed right away he does have his
chances here he can take in the center
and play Knight to c6 and we'll see how
crazy some of these lines get now you
you can't play d5 because you're a pawn
would be hanging and you need to be
careful how you defend your D pawn if
you just defend with the knight casually
this will run right into our Bishop g4
attacking one of the pieces that's
protecting the square and will probably
take it next and some you know some care
should be taken here white should
consider the move Bishop to e3 and if
I'm going fast and you're you can pause
your videos at home if at any point you
want to you want to think about that
position for yourself okay so now blacks
going to get his Bishop out he's going
to play e6 and okay well develop some
pieces black will develop and now
White's point of this is he gets to play
in the center
so d-5 trying to crush black before you
gets castled now night before
immediately is a move more common is
taking and all right so black is now
getting ready to jump into situ but
white is just in time with the move
Knight to D for protecting d2 and
attacking the bishop so blacks got to be
really careful here if you just casually
go back it's actually a big disaster
after this check that big is that but
you have to move your king which is not
what you want to be doing so much more
common is they drop back and he's about
to Castle but we can we can get the
movie six in okay and after the trades
what's going on here so white has a
really strong pawn it'll probably be
weak if black makes it to the endgame we
can take this Bishop whenever we want
and all right so we got to be be pretty
careful here as both colors now queen g4
and okay I'm going to go take this pawn
and blacks move you might not find if
you haven't seen this before but he has
a decent move with this this big check
here and white will lose a little bit of
material yeah now the rook is hanging
and so okay we reach a position like
this where you're going to win material
boy has great attacking chances now even
better than taking the bishop is the
castle I don't really have time to
demonstrate it but Knight to f5 is
actually a really uncomfortable threat
for black to meet so it's it's
surprisingly annoying how strong that
move is so he probably gets his queen
out and we take the bishop and you get
such a position
I don't think we'll go much farther than
that and this is the four pawns attack a
very crazy way for a white to play he's
trying to blow black off the board and
black should be careful and I've played
the alkyne a lot it used to be one of my
favorite openings so I never really
minded the four pawns attack I always
found it a little bit more annoying when
they just played normal solid moves and
didn't do very much so in the main line
they pinned the night here in an effort
to take the knight because this is
actually quite a nice piece it'll
usually end up going to e5 you don't
have to play this way you can take you
can play such a line in place
c6 and carlson has played this half a
dozen times with good results so that's
the way I used to play it but we'll go
over the main line all right and what's
just playing normal moves he'll play c4
later after he castles east six castles
and only now will white decide it's
about time for him to move some of these
pieces so he probably doesn't want to
put the knight in front of his pawn he
takes the opportunity to chase the night
away and okay we get such a position and
things can get really problematic for
black
that's all theory still but after we
develop a few more pieces the main move
here is d5 so what should white do it's
very interesting he gets the move c5 in
and now the knight is going to have to
move but before he does that black
usually tosses in this move which is
questionable if if this helps black or
not the point is if you take back with
the bishop which is possible I could do
that
you're given control over c4 and that's
where the Knights going to jump in and
well that is playable is probably in
blacks interest to open the G file at
some point he might be able to put a
rook there and get an attack on the King
and also he's going to play like f4 f5
at the right moment he's thinking about
checkmate and he has much more space so
I don't play this line because it looks
great for white alright and now an
interesting scenario the Alekhine Knight
joins is his buddy over there and you
don't often see two knights just sitting
right next to each other so very
interesting position and white can play
on both sides of the board I think this
is just a lot of fun for white
personally a cute little move here
before point is if you you take it I
play route b1 and then I'm going to go
attack your B pond and all right without
saying too much more you can see that
this you know why this is a very
provocative opening you're tempting
white to get the big center and you know
sometimes they hit the center you don't
get to fight for it enough and you get
crushed but sometimes they overextend
and that's what you're hoping to do when
they play the ala kine alright coming in
at number 7 we have the modern defense
this has been played over a hundred
thousand times which is two point six
five percent of all
for games still very small numbers but a
very relevant okay there's some people
that like to just play g6 against
anything and so this is the opening that
they'll play of course most critical is
just grabbing the center and the guy we
develop our bishop now there's there's
different lines that can occur here when
you don't contest the center directly
usually you're giving your opponents a
lot more time to choose whatever setup
they want so there's quite a lot of ways
white can play here we won't have time
to go over everything we'll just go over
one line normally they'll develop their
Knight they're not committing yet to
having a knight on f3 because they might
play the move F for themselves and this
is very similar to the pierce defense
which we'll come to in a bit but the
difference is in the pierce they've
already put their knight on f6 and
you're using pieces to control the
center so of all the ways white can try
to take advantage of this is okay one of
these moves and black can play Knight f6
will transpose into up here it's and
we'll we'll get a similar game that
we'll see later but okay we can you can
try to play some different move a six
and what's what's he doing why is he
playing on the side well ok he's a he's
gonna play b5 he's not going to Castle
right away he's mostly waiting to see
what white will do it's kind of a
waiting game wait how are you gonna
defend and then I'll tell you how I'm
going to set up all my pieces so a very
interesting way to play it's you know
it's not for everybody but it's quite
interesting and alright and now white
can castle Queen side and then black
will know where the king is and he might
be able to get an attack so okay
White's plan is kind of simple he's
going to play over here on the Kings
side for a bit
he'll Castle when he feels like it's
safe enough eventually Black has to
start developing pieces so okay he plays
for for c5 here and here we go h4 and
the most common move here is that not to
let white go and open the position at
all it's that to play h5 and black will
probably castle in the distant future
okay this move does allow the knight
jump into a pretty nice Square when you
played the move h5 you gave away the g5
Square a little bit so we'll develop
some pieces
we don't have a whole lot of time so
what kind of I know I'm zooming through
it a little bit but uh all right he's
really going to play c5 and okay and you
get such a position and I think this is
a fine to leave it here we we can see
black is sort of doing a wait-and-see
approach how are you going to develop
your pieces and you know when you are
castled you might see an attack whose
king is safer here that's sort of the
debate that's going on is a the White
King safer is the black King safer so
all in all it's kind of an interesting
approach not very very popular of course
but uh okay it's quite quite interesting
coming in at number six we have the
Scandinavian defense which has been
played 147 thousand times and we're up
to a three point six percent of all
games are the Scandinavian and we've
covered this before on this channel so
uh
okay well we'll see it one more time the
critical line is to take Knight f6 is
possible but almost always they take
with the Queen and you don't have to
play Knight to c3 you can try to play
lines where you wait to see if you can
get your your C pawn and deep ongoing
and then put your mate on c3 after
you've already played c4 but this is
critical and we've examined in a very
recent video that there's four moves
here d6 has been a favorite of TV yakov
that's very popular d8 the banker
variation that's also interesting
Carlson has played it and the Mike comer
variation I mean the Patzer variation so
okay Queen a sick or 25 sorry and white
puts a pawn in the center this is the
most common way for black to play and
we'll get our pieces out White's big
thing is at some point he's going to be
trying to play the move d5 when black
sets up his pawns here so Knight f3 not
only the most natural but often he he
wants this night to go to e5 pretty
early in the game that sort of thing can
happen a lot and this move is integral
to blacks plan at some point why it's
going to put a bishop here and then he's
going to move the knight away and it's
going to be a discovered attack so black
makes way for
Queen to escape in the future also the
pond is taking control over d5 which is
in his best interest so alright we'll
see what continues to fight for d5 well
actually get his Bishop out before he
plays the movie six and alright so we're
setting up for it we don't need to fear
it immediately and if you'll remember my
Scandinavian video I told you what's
that oh sorry I told in my Scandinavian
video in order for this this night move
to be really effective if you want to
have a good discovered attack you need
three key ingredients one is the bishop
needs to be protected otherwise whenever
the you know sometimes when you're
playing for d5 the Queen might get the
c5 square okay but uh and the black king
should be in the center and you should
have you know the night that can move
away with the with the bishop here
okay so we've protected the bishop if
you're asking do you just drop a pond
you can go watch the video to see what
happens if you do indeed accept the
sacrifice here it's not very good to
move d5 is very strong so this is the
only really move the black can play that
achieves something with with his move
here you know he has to be worried about
some discovered attacks anything else
White has a good night moves alright we
castle and we'll see in such positions
this is sort of the the main line it's
not the only line that we we covered in
the other video but it's worth seeing
what gets the two bishops so why would I
why would black play this way well
alright we'll go a few more moves just
so we can discuss the plan this is sort
of the the typical position we want to
keep our two bishops and why would you
get the two bishops well black has sort
of a plan white typically is going to be
playing on the Kings side over here and
what he's going to get in return for the
bishops is he's going to go open up the
h-file make this rook a good piece a
very typical maneuver is to get the
Queen to c5 with you know a nice pin
here on the C file and black will argue
okay I have some some really nice
activity and in exchange White has a
little bit more space
has the two bishops and it's a it's a
pretty even game so all right very nice
all right coming in at number five we
have the pierce defense which is very
similar to the modern defense and we'll
take a look again when you can take the
center you can do it so far we've seen
in most of these openings black is just
giving white the center and that's why
they're not as popular but here instead
of playing a move like g6 and and not
telling you where the Knights going to
go Knight f6
all right attacking the pawn well you
will typically defend it and there's so
many possible moves here for white if
you get a book about the pier it's it's
going to be 400 to 500 pages long
because there's so many possible ways
white can set up his pieces here we'll
go over the most aggressive and one of
the most common the Austrian attack and
okay white is intending you know I'm
going to play e5 at some point I'm going
to crush you in the center what are you
going to do so let's let's develop a few
more pieces and now there's a big branch
here there's massive Theory for the move
c5 there's massive theory for castles
castling is a little bit more popular
and here white has a ton of moves
historically the most popular is Bishop
to d3
you know Bishop to e3 is also a very
nice move it's getting it you know it's
pretty it's preventing c5 at least for
the moment and later you know he might
connect his his Bishop and queen and
eventually try to trade off the bishops
here but I couldn't help but show one of
my favorite games because there's a
really beautiful line so this is the one
time in the lecture I'm not going to go
over the the main main line here I want
to show you the move e5 and there was a
game that Nakamura played with the white
pieces and he just crushed his opponent
in a very very beautiful variation so I
I feel I must show you you could take on
e5 but okay his opponent decided to
retreat and h4 so what is really serious
about this attack black should you know
take some sort of action in the center
and white continues h5
black takes and now the most exciting
move this is why I've decided to show it
you can actually take here on g6
sacrificing a piece so this is one of
the wildest variations that you can you
can get here in chess so I just have to
show you okay we take and what's going
on here why did we give up a piece white
needs to get a strong attack here he's
got his bishop he's got some nights that
are coming in we got the rook here so
you can start to see you know he's got
some some really serious attackers
coming in and he's going to go try to
checkmate black so Bishop to c4 and ice
opponent played Knight to f8 a little
more common is a six with the tactical
point that if I take this what does
black play now you can pause your videos
at home see if you can find it but the
move black can play here is Knight to e5
so the point is if you take this rook we
we can take back and this should be
pretty good for black he's he traded
some some defenders here it's going to
be very similar to the game white just
simply won't take he'll play Knight to
g5 and so we'll see that in this
position so we got a very similar
situation and after the capture black
made sort of an interesting move here he
took this beep on which is tricky but
it's probably not the best move for him
because now most people will take the
knight this is a unknown position but
this is the first time and only time
somebody's done this but now White has
an extra attacker so you know what's
pretty serious about this this attack
and we'll see that happen so check no
big deal we'll move our king and now
yeah at some point you got to take this
and okay how is white going to finish
his attack here what can he do well you
can bring the Queen in a very good start
and now the key square he's going to
attack here is h7 he's it's unfortunate
that this Knight is here it's kind of a
pesky Knight but okay Bishop d3 we're
taking aim at age 7 so we're going to go
try to checkmate you
all right in the game he attacked the
bishop
so it was defended and black tries for
one more little trick he has a little
plan here he's going to try to put his
bishop over here on b5 try to trade off
one of those key attacking players so a
very nice move from mcaro c4 preventing
blacks idea and all right the Queen's
coming in he's got to be kind of pesky
here he's you know thinking about
grabbing one of these ponds with check
alright watch what's going to happen
well now we can take and after the the
trade black here played the the absolute
losing move he's he's in pretty bad
shape in this position but after this
white made one more move and black
resigned and it's kind of a quiet move
rook to h4 not only defending the pawn
but black is sort of powerless against
the move rook to g4 and you're just in a
lot of trouble here you can't get the
bishop out of the way or protected again
if you're if your king was here instead
maybe you could play Knight to c6 and
protect the bishop with your rook but uh
yeah so King to f8 didn't really work
for him and all right he saw it and he
said alright I give it up so very
interesting and very aggressive way to
play and that's what happens when you
don't contest the center from the
beginning your opponent can you know get
a huge center and they can try to crush
you really quickly okay coming in at
number four we got the caro-kann and now
we're getting into a much more typical
openings we're starting to get some big
numbers here this one played 287
thousand times or seven percent of all
the four games and it begins with the
move c6 now we've covered this before so
we're going to take another look at it
and this is blacks point he didn't
contest the center on move one he waits
until move two and then he strikes in
the center so white has a couple options
here he can play the exchange boo
he can play the advance which is a very
serious consideration right now at the
top level it's one of White's best tries
for an advantage or you can play either
Knight move and usually they'll they'll
transpose if black decides to take on e4
okay we take back and here there's
actually three moves we've covered the
classical before we'll take
or look at it but it's also possible to
play a move like Knight f6 and in this
position we can take and now whichever
way you take back black is going to say
I'm going to get some pretty dynamic
activity for my piece here this is the
Bronstein Larsen variation he's going to
try to use this you know if and he's
it's a very interesting variation but
it's it's not for today
the Steinitz variation also is
interesting Karpov use this over a
hundred times in his career and okay
you're just gonna play Knight f6 and
that way if you trade I don't have to
weaken my pawn structure but most common
the classical variation you attack the
knight and you got your bishop outside
of the pawn chain so now when you play a
six you'll be looking good alright so we
harass the bishop and the one feature
that does stick out in blacks position
is this Bishop white can you know
continue to try to get it each for
threatening to trap the bishop so you
got to make some space and the most
accurate move here is not h5 it's a
Knight f3 the reason is if you play any
move other than Knight to d7 I'm jumping
into e5 which is usually pretty annoying
especially when I can reinforce it with
an F pawn so Knight to d7 alright now we
attack the bishop it has to go back
Bishop d3 so this is a you know this
this Bishop is quite annoying that's a
good Bishop over there so white
endeavors to trade it off and black
should take otherwise they can get the
Danny Machuca rook right this happened
to you this is what happened in your
game with Jonathan Israel and you got
the end was there yeah it was a
different opening but yeah
yeah you don't want the Machuca rook
it's not the best rook so he took on d3
and Knight f6 and e6 are usually the
same deal and I recommended the move
Bishop to d2 in my previous video
historically more popular is Bishop to
f4 and okay this is obviously the more
active square for the bishop but now
black has sort of a pesky little move
Queen to a5 check the point is you're
probably
drop your bishop back well it doesn't
want to play a move like c3 because he's
going to Castle over on the Queen side
and he doesn't want a week in the
position so white will drop back and so
the Queen got to c7 and we'll just go a
few more moves will develop some pieces
and all right so now what at what to do
typically in these positions you know
we're going to try to get out of the way
here so we can move our Jeep on it seems
kind of strange if you want to like
trade pieces here but you got to get out
of the way the Jeep on and we looked at
games where black castles on the
kingside but we'll have a stop here and
this is a very interesting position and
yeah it's been covered before coming in
at number three is a personal favorite
of mine the French defense which has
been played in more than 500,000 games
and the numbers are starting to get big
here it's been in twelve point nine nine
percent of all efore games
so almost thirteen percent and so this
is the French again the most critical is
to play d4 and similar to the caro-kann
we strike in the center so here there
are four moves you can play the exchange
boo you can play the advance which is
it's quite a lot different than the the
caro-kann or you can play the tirage or
the classical way so very similar to the
caro-kann in that way okay but Knight c3
is the main move my preferred move here
is just the most natural I put my my
knight on f6 but a more popular and more
aggressive is the move Bishop to b4 so
what is this why would you develop your
bishop before your knight doesn't that
break one of the the big rules and what
are you going to do give away your
dark-squared bishop often in the French
you need your Bishop over by your king
for defense so we're going to get some
pretty exciting games here the exchange
is possible also possible here is this
gambit though it's a bit dubious the
most common move here is e v and okay so
the big break that you want to get in
when you're black in the French is c5 so
you can play it here and there's many
many variations this is a pretty deep
theory now that we're getting
- but a3 is the most common trying to
get the the bishop pair now black almost
always takes the knight if you go back
white actually has a cute little move
b4x clam so he's trying to temporarily
block this diagonal so he can jump his
knight in and try to go harass the king
so that's why in this position black
will almost always take this Knight let
me take back okay it's more than one
line here we'll develop our Knight and
there's a lot of moves the most critical
is that going and Rasim the King so you
can castle here you'll notice that a
bishop to h6 is not a threat because you
can block without having to give up your
rook so yeah I saw one person that
thought he couldn't play this because uh
because of this move but okay so
castling is you know almost tied for the
as most popular as the more interesting
variation which is Queen to c7 the
poisoned pawn variation so if you don't
take the pawn I mean why do you put your
Queen on g4 and alright so white grabs a
pond tax the rook the rook better move
it'll take that pawn - so here we're
going to get something pretty crazy
there's a lot of stuff going on why did
we give up a pawn
Black's going to hope for some really
active play and we'll see immediately he
could cause some problems in the center
and he has a big threat let's uh let's
not take this because then what is black
play yeah yeah Queen c3 forking the the
king and rook so care must be taken it's
interesting so I mean 92 is the most
popular move here it's funny to mention
that King to d1 is also a move and it's
one of my favorite bad moves to make
because I was playing a feed a master
and then some you know random position I
just played King to d1 and after the
game he said why did you play King d1
was no it was some position nobody would
ever think about playing King d1 I just
did it so it's a bad move I like to play
sometimes
okay 92 is the the main line here and
it's known to be a bit too risky for
black to grab this guy he gets a good
position either after a bishop to f4 or
simply taking here on d4 he doesn't
really want to go into an endgame based
on the fact that well white has this
past pawn so this is going to be coming
and you have a lot of weak dark squares
and so often this doesn't work the
Knights and the fact that we have a dark
squared Bishop are really handy for
white so this position is quite good for
white which is why okay they attacked it
again we should defend the pawn we don't
to give up our big central pawn here and
okay black is ready to castle he can
also take on c3 first if he so desires
and typically we bring our Queen back
our queen wasn't really doing anything
over there so we bring it back to the
center and now we take okay and now it's
dispositions we played several times and
both recaptures lead to different types
of positions but we'll just we'll leave
it here with sort of a basic idea
Black's going to Castle over here he is
down a pawn what is he going to get for
his pawn well he's going to have some
really nice squares for his Knights so
he's counting on this active play now I
was playing a master once and it was
funny
we got a position like this though he
miss played it and I just did this and
then I just won like he never stopped me
so it was really strange
I just ran my pawn and I made a queen
and then I won so that was that was a
strange way so that each pawn is
typically part of White's plan he's
going to get moving really fast a lot of
the times you might also consider
putting the bishop on the diagonal here
to cut off the rook a little bit but
it's at least a very exciting chess all
right number two we have the King's pawn
opening so this is you know one of the
most popular moves and this is a very
serious number the top two moves are
almost all of the games and this has
been played over a million times and
more than 25% of all games that start
with e4 see the reply e5 and okay we'll
just we'll put a few normal moves on the
board there's other lines and here
there's there's
romaine moves for the Scotch you can go
see my video on this opening for the
Italian game you can watch any beginner
breakdown video ever it's like a 50%
chance that they've covered this or you
could play the route Lopez which is the
most popular so that's what we're going
to take a look at and alright it's hard
to cover the rui lopez in just a couple
minutes it really deserves a bit more
time so hopefully people request a
little bit more of it because it is an
opening I intend to go more thoroughly
into in some other videos alright a six
now it might seem at first like okay I
put my Bishop on b5 so I can take your
knight and then I can take the pawn here
on e5 but you'll see that this is not
the most common variation you do not
just win upon here white you Castle or
play d3 or Knight to c3 but in this
position I know he sees it but what's
what's blacks idea here why did he allow
this what does black play Queen e7 okay
you do have a little bit better yeah
Queen d4 a double attack
so okay you don't want to lose your
unite so that you'll drop your knight
back and typically we'll get this check
and now this is a funny thing happened
here at the club I don't know you might
have been playing in this tournament but
it was in a knight's tournament where
white played a great move here but not
very legal he castled and you okay the
computer won't let me do it but alright
that happened it was like a game between
a 1500 with the white pieces and a 1300
with the black pieces and nobody noticed
till after the game but yeah white one
quickly because if you can castle and
then put your rook on e1 you win quickly
that would just refute this opening
instead you know you'll get a position
more like this and okay white doesn't
really have any big advantage that's you
want a little bit more as white so more
typical let's drop our Bishop back and
okay several moves here for black the
most common Knight f6
and after we Castle we haven't defended
our e-pawn we can pick here as black do
we want an open game or a closed game
very popular at the high level right now
is just to play the the open variation
and why to play either rookie one or
more commonly the move d4 and the
position will open up though
historically much more popular is the
closed variation where you don't take
the pawn you instead okay develop your
pieces and we defend the pawn now that
the pawn is defended we are thinking
about grabbing this this pawn here
taking the knight and then grabbing it
so black kicks the bishop away okay and
let's let's play here let's defend our
piece now now that the the e pawn is
protected by another pawn black is
thinking about playing the move Knight
to a5 grabbing the bishop and if you
play the reuleaux PES a lot you really
love this Bishop so you you want to make
a little space for them so if he gets
attacked
you can go back here and even though
there's a pawn in the way sometimes he's
very useful in a King side attack and
okay here there's there's a lot of moves
but after h3 now this is where most
people are picking which variation they
want to go into so it's interesting to
know what you guys might want to see
from this position there's the the
Zaitsev variation where you put your
Bishop on the diagonal puts a lot of
pressure on the the center there's the
brayer where the knight will reroute to
a the d7 also very interesting and the
most popular is a unite to a5 followed
by a quick c5 this is the chigorin
defense and it feels you know like I
don't really want to go too much into
the opening here because we simply don't
have the the time and out of respect for
the opening we'll wait till we can go a
little bit deeper in the number one most
popular response to e4 hopefully a lot
of you know it it's the Sicilian defense
and we've gone over a little bit of this
it's been played over a million and a
half times and it counts for thirty nine
point five percent of all
so when you play e4 you almost always
get the Sicilian that seems true in my
practice it's you know very typical
blacks not just trying to equalize he's
actually trying to fight for an
advantage here so that's one way black
can control the other d4 square you'll
notice and c5 are both fighting against
White's immediate plan which is to put
two pawns in the center but we want to
still play d4 let's just get our night
out first and so many moves here you
know all these like everything is a move
here but all right we'll look at d6 it's
the most popular and we're going to see
an opening that we've seen very recently
after we we take black kids to say
alright I traded a side pawn for a
central pawn so a lot of end games will
favor black white gets to say I'm going
to get a lot more activity and I'm going
to show that I can get an initiative
from the beginning and convert that into
some sort of advantage in the middle
game and okay white if black you know
doesn't do anything he's probably
thinking about playing a move like c4 so
he stops it by attacking the pawn and
getting white to put the knight in front
of his C pawn now what's the most common
move in this position there's a lot of
moves here a six yeah so we've we've
covered this in my last video I guess so
we covered this just a couple weeks ago
so this is not the most popular and we
went over quite a lot of possible moves
here there's a lot of moves and we
ultimately took a good look at the
English attack so today we'll look at
something a little bit different spice
it up play a much more aggressive move
and this is often thought to be the way
black should play or one should play if
he's trying to prove that he can refute
the knight orff so this leads to some
really insane stuff this is some of the
most critical stuff in all of chess very
exciting positions we'll take a little
look and white plays the move f4
intending e5 he's just going to do this
so normally black will stop him here
there's actually three really
interesting moves
that's probably untrue this is this move
is also probably interesting but uh okay
the classical way of playing is just to
get your develop your bishop that way if
you play e5 there's there's no pain
but there's some crazier stuff for
example you can play Queen to b6 and
this also is called the poison pond
variation you can protect your B pond
but it's it's more typical to allow
black to take it and Knight to b3 is a
move rope to b1 is a move and we can't
go into all of this
you know today but it's it's very
exciting and white will either play
after this move you'll either play e5 or
f5 and like super grandmasters will say
it's all been worked out to a draw but
if you watch a lot of these games
they're crazy and wild and the draw
lines are all ridiculous so it's it's a
lot of fun just even if you don't want
to play this opening it's a lot of fun
just to look at some of the poisoned
pawn games just add a sheer interest
okay it's also possible to play the move
b5 this is the pool guy upski variation
and so wait a minute you just let me
play e5 and all right what's your your
big cutting point here black will take
its you might be thinking maybe you can
get away with kicking this bishop away
this way boy gets a pretty decent
position this isn't what we're going to
look at but okay you can see why it has
a pretty nice position and this is known
to be pretty good for him so alright
that variation this is just out so we'll
look at what they really do first black
takes white takes and now there's a
tactical justification for why it's for
blacks move here and that's Queen to c7
so if white takes the knight and he
should the whole point I hope you can
see it at home pause your videos if you
haven't seen it yet its Queen to e5
attacking the King and the bishop okay
so white should I develop this piece and
a very interesting situation has arised
now White has like developed all of his
pieces and even the Queen is pretty good
on the open file and can black really
survive like this can he just move his
Queen around a whole bunch that's going
to be sort of the focus of the game and
since this has been played so often
Black has come up with some interesting
defensive resources because white is
about to get a huge initiative here he's
going to put is a bishop on the open
diagonal you know some of these pieces
are going to start jumping in here
it can cause a lot of problems for for
black so actually the most common move
here is a as a surprising move rook to
a7
the point is it's hard for black to ever
develop this night because if it ever
moves you're given away control over c6
which is very dangerous this also
doesn't help blacks case because after
Bishop to f3 I will just we'll just look
at this for a second white is as a very
strong attack here and uh okay black
should be really really careful yeah we
don't want to give move the knight and
give away control over c6
so instead rope to a7 and the point is
we're going to go put our bishop on d7
never get it rook on d7 then we're going
to put our Bishop on b7 and we're going
to fight against some of weights
attacking ideas and alright maybe
another day we'll get to cover all this
this crazy and wild stuff I mean it
leads to some of the most beautiful
games in chess and historically just
some of the greatest games they've ever
been played have come in this in lines
like this okay you know yeah we
shouldn't we shouldn't forget Bishop to
e7 let's see and we'll just go over one
line here really quick alright would so
if you just play normal moves while you
can try to attack black blow them off
the board he'll attack in the center and
after some trades you know we kick the
knight around and that we get very
interesting game so this this also is a
very common way to play and hopefully we
get to take a look at it in depth
sometime okay so I hope you enjoyed the
top ten list if this is something that
you want to see again in the future let
me know do you have ideas top ten
anything we could do a top ten d4 top
ten Sicilians top ten anti Sicilians
what do you guys want to see did you
like it I know it's the handicap is that
we don't really get to go in depth in
everything that I'd like to do so it
should be interesting to see what you
guys have to say and as usual keep
sending in all of your submissions for
opening so we might want to do in the
future hit like hit share hit a lot of
buttons and I'll see you guys next week
Oh